one day we'll uh we'll wake up and brush
our teeth and we'll go to work
at some point we'll suddenly realize
and we haven't thought about it at all
hey guys pete here today i'm going to
preview what we can expect in episode 9
of better call saul's final season
before we get going i do want to say
that i think there's a real chance that
we might not get any more teasers that
show upcoming scenes because there are
so many big surprises baked into the
potential time skips that might happen
the teaser i'll be talking about today
is a continuation of the mysterious ones
they put out during the mid-season break
they don't give a lot away they make you
think about what's to come without
showing it to you but on top of that
there are some episode 9 photos the
official synopsis and some news about
the new character to talk about if any
of that sounds like spoilers to you then
this is your chance to leave and with
that out of the way let's get into it
the title of episode 9 is fun and games
and the official synopsis reads gus
attempts to smooth things over with the
cartel while mike ties up loose ends
north of the border this feels a little
strange to me the promo photos do
include shots of juan bolsa donald audio
and gus together in mexico you can't
really say for sure that's where gus is
in the photo but given the synopsis it
makes sense and to me it also looks like
he's standing there looking at don
oladio's pool which brings to mind that
fateful day when max was killed what's
strange is that it feels unnecessary for
his story for him to be there the cartel
believes that lalo died at his hacienda
so none of what's happened since nacho's
death changes anything there are issues
to deal with but none of it seems
crucial it makes me wonder if he goes
there as a way to get him out of
albuquerque because the story needs him
not to be there if mike is supposed to
tie up loose ends maybe he wants him to
do something that he can't follow
through on if he weren't around that
would give mike the chance to say he did
whatever he wanted him to without him
looking over his shoulder this is on my
mind because kim now knows where he
lives and that could be seen as her
knowing too much at the same time i'm
not sure why he would want her
eliminated and not jimmy so i'm not in
love with this idea but i did think it
was worth considering since something
has to get kim to leave town or at the
very least bring their relationship to
an end the official teaser amc released
after episode 8 is an 11 second black
and white shot of saul goodman's office
that looks like it did in the breaking
bad timeline there are no signs of
francesca's hard work in decorating it
when saul first moved in which presents
the question of when and why did he
redecorate the only other thing that
happens is that jimmy says that one day
they'll wake up and brush their teeth
and go to work and at some point they'll
suddenly realize that they haven't
thought about it at all so not a ton of
content but as with the other recent
teasers i still find this fascinating
for a couple of reasons
first what jimmy says is almost a word
for word parrot job of what mike told
him when he was having trouble going
back to work after their trip through
the desert that's interesting because at
the time he didn't find the advice very
useful and in reality still hasn't
recovered from that because season 5
came out such a long time ago it's easy
to forget that when they started putting
their plan against howard into action
jimmy was still noticeably sunburnt from
that trip some time has passed now but
these traumatic situations have just
been following one after the other in
jimmy's life it also sounds like he's
saying this to kim who just had the
equivalent of her trip through the
desert even if jimmy was falling apart
you would expect him to try to lift him
up but it's at least possible that he's
better equipped to put on the facade and
go back to living his life because of
his ability to stuff these kinds of
things down rather than feel them and i
mean relatively anyway he was an
absolute mess before he started to
bounce back as they were putting things
in motion against howard he never led on
that chuck's death was bothering him but
it certainly came out in other ways
regardless saying this to kim makes it
seem like she's having trouble i think
there's something to what mike said
about her being made of sterner stuff
but the last 24 hours would be difficult
for anyone i suppose it depends on when
he's actually saying this this could be
right after mike leaves he might be
doing what he tried to do when he quoted
her this same conversation saying that
dropping mesa verde was putting her on
bad choice road i tend to think that
she's been the more capable of the two
and it's pretty clear that she thought
this as well i believe that's why she
didn't tell him about running into mike
and finding out that lala wasn't dead
but it's still very possible that she
might be having trouble acting like
everything is normal in a post-howard
world and we'll come back to that in a
minute the second thing about this
teaser is related to something i noticed
about the last one they put out before
episode 8. this same shot of the office
is even included in that one and instead
of quoting mike he's saying something
that we heard chuck say to howard the
thing that jumped out to me in that
teaser is that it starts out with
lifeless interior and exterior shots of
familiar places it focuses on the inside
and outside of saul's office los pollos
and kim's apartment before it gets to
the big reveal shot of saul and his
mansion during breaking bad the
lifelessness and lack of color adds a
bleakness to the black and white shots
which reminds you of gene but i don't
think that this is an indication that
we'll be visiting omaha in the next
episode the thing we've been witnessing
is the traces of good that were in jimmy
when we first met him being stripped
away much like the color has been
stripped from the image of his office so
it makes me think of the saul goodman
persona that jimmy has been crafting
over the past two seasons because this
prequel did add another dimension to the
garish criminal lawyer we met in
breaking bad sure jimmy mcgill has
always had a slippery side but when we
meet him at the beginning of better call
saul he's a long way away from sleazy
which is something he definitely is in
the original series at least on the
outside knowing who he was and who he'll
become makes me wonder how much of jimmy
is still there on the inside
the gene timeline has gotten darker if
you really think about it originally
that lack of color and him being on his
own toiling away at cinnabon seemed
awful for the guy we knew to be such a
colorful character now it's starting to
look like who he was in breaking bad was
more about him not being able to deal
with the consequences of the choices
he's made the one shot we've seen of him
in the mansion doesn't look like a
version of jimmy that's living his best
life of course things do go wrong when
he starts working with walter white but
how right were they before he walked in
that door it's a very interesting
question and it makes me reconsider the
idea of him sitting in that apartment in
omaha watching those vhs tapes of his
saw commercials kim is not there and in
the next couple of episodes we're gonna
know for sure why that is the other
promo photo that caught my attention was
one of cliff maine it's kind of been up
in the air of who they'll be dealing
with in this aftermath of howard's
disappearance the shot of cliff makes me
wonder if he'll ask her why she missed
that meeting and that feels like a
conversation that could be a pressure
point because what can she even say the
other bit of news is there's a tweet
that seems to indicate that carol
burnett will show up in the next episode
at mavericks movies who seems to know a
lot about the industry and awards
tweeted out that a certain actor from
better call saul will presumably be
eligible for guest actor next year for
the second half of this season for their
performance in this week's episode they
have officially announced that carol
burnett will be a guest actor and if
he's right that there aren't any others
you can put two and two together and if
that's not enough when someone brought
this up in the replies he responded with
a gif of her this makes me think that
she's probably playing judge pompadumian
since we know that jimmy will be going
back to the courtroom and if he has a
meltdown or something else happens that
seems like a pretty good place for her
to step into the role of this character
that's been name-dropped in both series
the other idea is that she could play
howard's mother i never really liked
this one that much i'm presuming that
they do get the settlement money since
he put some money into that mansion and
i just don't know because they already
have plenty to regret in what happened
to howard i don't see pressure from his
family making a big difference but i
have seen that a lot of people like this
idea we'll be finding out pretty soon
and i think that's a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you think about the teaser in the photos
and what you expect to see in episode 9.
going into making this i wasn't thinking
this could be the last episode where we
see kim and jimmy together but the more
i thought about it the more possible it
started to seem please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon